[Musik]
hallo wir sind kari und janus und wir
drehen jede woche videos für euch zum
deutsch lernen hier soll ich mindestens
50 cent mehr
hast du auch schon mal kein trinkgeld
gegeben nie fühlt sich gut und jetzt
erstmal auf der ganzen welt volljährig
wir drehen videos auf der straße denn
wir möchten euch zeigen wie deutsch
tatsächlich gesprochen wird wie gefällt
ihnen heute das wetter
mein beruf ist kesha und was brauchst du
freizeit freizeit ein fachmann machen
wir heißen die siegerin nicht weil
deutsch einfach ist sondern weil wir es
euch einfach machen möchten deutsch zu
lernen
das kann man in berlin unternehmen um
diese wetter nicht zu entkommen
ganz viele schöne cafés gehen und damit
ihr optimal deutsch lernen könnt haben
all unsere videos untertitel auf deutsch
und auf englisch eine frage die wand
einer dhabi stellen darf dann lügen sie
okay es lohnt sich auch ein mitglied von
easy german zu werden denn als mitglied
erhaltet ihr jede woche interaktive
übungen vokabel listen und vieles mehr
um euer deutsch weiter zu verbessern zum
strukturierten deutsch lernen empfehlen
wir euch außerdem unsere app siedlung in
der app findet ihr interaktive video
flash cards mit denen ihr schritt für
schritt die deutsche grammatik und die
wichtigsten vokabeln für die tägliche
interaktion lernen könnt seid ihr
bereits zum deutsch lernen
dann abonniert unseren kanal werdet ein
mitglied von easy german und probiert
unsere apps siedlung aus los geht's
ich habe donnerstags immer schon
wochenende und da fühle ich mich dann
immer schon sehr jungen wenn das
wochenende gerade los geht meistens
fahre ich dann das ganze wochenende
durch und sonntags fühle ich mich dann
sehr sehr alt